good morning good morning everyone
everyone
today i am joined by minister arghabra
and minister boisono as well as dr new
who is joining us also virtually
last week on march 11th we marked the
second anniversary of the pandemic
it was a day
to mourn those
people who have died from covet 19 37
000 people to recognize those who have
contracted the disease and those who
continue to suffer its effects
and the fact that they're keeping it
that they're continuing to suffer its
effects it was also a day to recognize
and to thank the healthcare workers who
have sacrificed so much
and who have spent the last two years on
the front lines to protect us
after two years of following individual
public health measures
people in canada know what to do to keep
themselves and each other safe as i've
already mentioned in the past
we are in a much better position today
than in 2020
high vaccination rates and
strong adherence to public health
measures have pushed us through the peak
of the omicron wave
we have more tools
like widely available rapid tests
and a range of new treatments
that
and further to our february announcement
we can now announce other changes at the
border
starting april 1st 2022
fully vaccinate people
will no longer
have to be required to complete a
pre-entry test for travel to canada
fully vaccinated travelers
may still be selected to undergo random
testing upon entry
and partially vaccinate travis will
continue to be tested with covenant
molecular tests on arrival
and on day 8.
while they quarantine
for 14 days
all travelers
today's announcement is encouraging
but i will remind you
all measures are subject to review
we will continue to adjust them
as the epidemiological situation
evolves
you have followed border measures if you
choose to travel
and you follow local public health
advice your cooperation is helping the
country transition to the next phase of
the pandemic
living with coven 19 means that we will
continue to exercise that power
and make prudence
smart choices for
our communities and ourselves
last week on march the 11th we marked
the second anniversary of the pandemic
that was a day to mourn those who have
died from covet 19 and to recognize
those who have contracted the disease as
well as those who continue to suffer its
effects it was also a day to recognize
and thank the health care workers who
have sacrificed so much over the last
two years and spend that time on the
front lines to protect all of us
after two years of following individual
public health measures canadians know
what to do to keep themselves and each
other safe
as i've mentioned in the past we are in
a much better position now in march 2022
than we were in march 2020
high vaccination rates and strong
adherence to public health measures have
pushed us through the peak of the
omicron wave
we have more tools
available now like the wide availability
of rapid tests and a range of new
treatments that can help keep some
patients from getting seriously ill
i think it's fair to say that we are now
entering into a transition phase of this
pandemic
as the weather warms and people spend
more time outside we can expect to see
transmission decline in the coming
months but we have to be prepared for a
waning of collective and individual
immunity
of course the government of canada will
also keep monitoring for new variants
through our robust surveillance system
and adjust public health measures as
necessary
in the meantime and to build our on our
last announcement in february we are now
ready to announce further changes to
border measures
effective april 1st 2022
fully vaccinated travelers will no
longer be required to complete a
pre-entry test for travel to canada
fully vaccinated travelers may still may
still continue to undergo random testing
upon entry to canada but they are no
longer required to quarantine while
awaiting their results
unvaccinated and partially vaccinated
travelers will continue to be tested
with kovite 19 molecular tests on
arrival and on the 8th while the
quarantine for 14 days
all travelers are also required to
complete a ryze scan online or through
the free mobile app before entry to
canada
today's announcement is encouraging but
let us remember that all measures are
subject to review
we will continue to adjust them as the
epidemiological situation here in canada
and abroad evolves
finally i would like to thank canadians
for doing their part getting vaccinated
and for many of you getting boosted and
following public health advice
we have the power individually and
collectively to reduce the impact of the
virus on our lives
living with covet 19 means that we want
to continue to exercise that power and
make prudent smart choices for ourselves
and for those we love
thank you and i will now turn it over to
minister al gabra
mexi johnny bonjour thank you johnny
good morning to everyone
i want to begin by acknowledging that
i'm joining you today from the
traditional territory of the
mississaugas of the credit first nation
today is a day that many of us have been
waiting for
it is a great day for canadian travelers
tourism and aviation
this is good news said all along
that we would adjust our border measures
based on public health recommendation
and that is exactly what we are doing
today
i also want to highlight what removing
pre-entry testing will mean for cruise
ship travelers when the season starts in
early april
passengers on a cruise
will need to take an antigen test no
more than one day before the scheduled
departure but will no longer be required
to be tested before getting off the
cruise ship
all other aspects of the public health
framework for cruises that i announced
last week in halifax such as the
requirement to be vaccinated in order to
board will remain in place
as minister duklow noted the revised
border measures we're announcing today
are possible thanks to the millions of
canadians who have stepped up
rolled up their sleeves and gotten
vaccinated
merci vutus
that the health and safety of canadians
remains a priority and we will still
have the necessary safety measures in
place for travelers
the safety of canadians are our priority
for example our government is investing
in canada's airports to support testing
and screening for kobit 19 to make the
travel experience as safe and as
convenient as possible
and just last monday i announced a major
investment at pearson airport and more
announcements are coming
we also continue to have measures such
as the obligation to be vaccinated to
take a plane or a train in canada and
wearing a mask in canadian airports and
on planes
but as we've always said
public health measures are temporary and
we will adjust them based on public
health recommendations
and as we move to this next step i want
to thank our airlines airports tourism
operators travelers and all workers in
the air sector and cruise industry for
their tireless work over the past two
years
it has not been easy
but all of them have stepped up
and now i would like to turn it over to
my colleague minister wasanu
thank you very much merci
well thank you very much uh minister
algabra minister khloe dr nook
what a pleasure to be with you here
today for this big announcement
colleagues i want to acknowledge that
today i'm joining you from calgary and
from the lands of treaty seven peoples
the territorial lands of people who make
treaty seven their home
there's no denying that the tourism
sector has been uniquely affected uh
throughout the pandemic and as many of
you know in the in the past few months
i've heard from and met so many
inspiring entrepreneurs organizations
and businesses in canada's tourism
sector
who worked hard to keep their operations
afloat to reinvent themselves and to
continue to find creative ways to get
through this global pandemic and since
becoming minister of tourism i've heard
their concerns
i've also seen resilience and an
innovative spirit that has been
inspiring for all of us i can't help but
thinking of tourism entrepreneurs like
tina dixon from whitehorse who told me
recently that she just wanted to get
back to work it's been way too long of a
break
to tina and all the incredible people
who make up our sector you should all be
proud of what you've managed to
accomplish during these difficult times
and today's announcement has been
eagerly anticipated by canada's tourism
industry my friends the time has finally
come
today we announced the lifting of
testing requirements for fully
vaccinated travelers
canada's tourism sector is ready to
ensure the safety of travelers employers
and the communities in which they
operate they are ready to welcome back
the world as you know the government of
canada is deeply invested in seeing our
sector the tourism sector thrive once
again
budget 2021 introduced a three-year 1
billion dollar commitment to the sector
we have had your backs committing more
than 15 billion dollars in total support
to the tourism arts and culture sectors
through this pandemic and this includes
the 500 million dollar tourism relief
fund which was created to help tourism
businesses and operators adapt to our
new reality while setting the stage for
future growth
since december we've rolled out an
additional 12 billion dollars in support
we did this because we know that the
canadian economy will not fully recover
until our tourism sector recovers too
and that recovery is now at hand with
the reduction in travel restrictions
announced today notably removing the
requirement for fully vaccinated
travelers to submit a pre-entry cope
with 19 test results we are making it
easier for people from around the world
to visit canada this spring and beyond
and they will come
with our high vaccination rates and our
focus on health and safety canada has a
huge advantage in attracting visitors
because they know it's safe to travel to
canada we know the best way to overcome
the extraordinary challenges of the last
two years is by coming together in a
spirit of partnership and collaboration
across all levels of government and with
the sector
we know that the best way to overcome
the obstacles of the last two years is
to work together at all government
levels and within the tourist
industry for this reason we are removing
19 restrictions for fully vaccinated
people today
vibrant cities and cultural and historic
treasures and they want to come back for
more and i think of my recent visits one
to the indigenous peoples experience in
fort edmonton park and one on a guided
tour of stanley park with candace from
tallay say tours and these experience
can offer a glimpse into the rich
diversity of first nations inuit and
metis culture from coast to coast to
coast indigenous tourism is
reconciliation in action
i think of how canada has been named a
top destination for lgbtq2 travelers who
are drawn in part because of canada's
hallmark safety and security but there's
more to it we are an inclusive and
caring society i think about our strong
appeal for those seeking a francophone
language and cultural experience
and experience
and for those who are looking for a
franklin experience here we are while
you're focusing on kickstarting a
comeback the whole of our government is
there shoulder to shoulder with you we
will lead
we will engage and we will inspire i've
said it on numerous occasions safety
first then travel with the changes
announced today i say to everyone around
the world make canada your next trip
we have it all
beautiful breathtaking landscapes
internationally acclaimed festivals
premier national parks and outdoor
recreation diverse options from northern
peaks to our downtown course and first
and foremost safety venezuela
come experience it for yourself mel c
thank you hi hi
and now moderator over to you
wait miss here
thank you we'll take questions now five
minutes for questions we have a heart
stop at 11 30.
uh just a reminder to mute yourself
between your question and your follow-up
so we will start with kevin gallagher
ctv news
good morning my questions for minister
jukhloe um you know specifically when it
comes to
vaccine mandates for passengers on
planes and trains i mean obviously this
is still an effect i think the question
really is um we know that through waning
immunity and also um the vaccine's
effectiveness on the omicron variant
that the two shots is simply less
effective but not nearly as effective as
it was so you know
the federal government seems does have a
choice now um will the vaccine mandate
remain for travelers on planes and
trains or will fully vaccinated as a
definition have to incorporate three
shots so what decision do you think the
federal government will make
well thank you kevin those are very good
questions and
let me answer in three different ways
first as we know to the announcement
today is around no pre-entry testing
rules for vaccinated travelers that
doesn't impact the rules around
unvaccinated travelers second
the vaccination rules for entering into
canada are rules that are decided in
obviously based on the advice and the
insights of public health officials
we're also working with international
partners because obviously when
planes travel in both directions so we
we we are working with international
partners on establishing
those rules as you said based on the
uh what we know from an epidemiological
perspective but also from a virological
uh perspective so you are correct also
in alluding to the fact that booster
doses are
a consensus that booster doses are
needed a three-dollar
regime is a primary series regime that
most experts agree to and finally i
would point that the fact that
that all obviously depends on the
evolution of possible things on which we
have little uh evidence and of certainly
no control which is the arrival of
possibly a possible new variance of
future waste so all of this is based all
of these decisions so they are based on
the current um
measure of the situation on prudence on
precaution but also on the the knowledge
and the acknowledgement that these will
continue to be
addressed and possibly evolved
so
will
you change
the qualification for fully vaccinated
you know just fully vaccinated will that
soon mean you need to have
three doses you need to have that
booster shot is that going to be is that
going to meet the definition of fully
vaccinated for the canadian government
a there is no change to the definition
of a fully uh vaccinated canadian
b you are correct in saying that we
should keep encouraging canadians to get
a booster dose as a as a a way to
broaden and secure their protection
against uh against the virus and see it
is true that in other countries they are
contemplating that
if you look at
france and and denmark for instance
you'll see that a third dose is included
in their definition of of fully
vaccinated people but that's their
their decision and we are making our own
decisions in canada
particularly in south korea
we have seen
climbing
cases in the provinces
does that concern you at
are you all to contemplate to
introducing additional measures here in
canada
first of all
let's be clear everyone has understood
that
covert 19.
the second thing is that in canada
we are lucky that we have come through
this much better than a lot of other
countries
and it's important to remember
also that here in canada
we
efficiently vaccinated millions of
canadians
and among those who were vaccinated uh
twice
i think we have we have a rate of uh
over 81 percent
and a lot of canadians have got a
booster dose as well so
we know or we're hoping that in a few
weeks
we'll be protected
individually and collectively
so
nothing has been won yet with respect to
coven 19. covet will continue to be with
us for a very long time but in canada
we have come through it quite well now
and with our immunity rate in the
country
i think that we will do very well over
the next few weeks and months
we've heard that the w.h.o
not be purchasing
the quebec vaccine because of the philip
morris incident what do you think of
that what do you think of this
opportunity
and what impact will this have on the
management of vaccines in canada will it
have an
impact on the kovacs uh what do you
think
very well
so two very good things about medicare
first of all
as everyone probably knows this is a
canadian company
one of the rare canadian companies that
over the past few months have been able
to develop and now produce a canadian
vaccine
we can all be very proud of this
given that
we found out that during
the start of cover 19 that our
pharmaceutical capacity
and declined seriously over the past few
years the second good piece of news with
respect to medical is that it's a
vaccine
it's the first
canadian vaccination that has been
approved by health canada but in
addition this is a
vaccine that's used new technology
and this could be broadened
and there's other vaccines that it would
be involved as well
so this is a new technology
that will complete the
technology provided by other types of
vaccines obviously we're following
[Music]
uh we're looking at the exchanges
between who and medical and minister
xiaopeng and i have contacted medico to
make sure that it's
contact with who is done properly
so that everyone not only here in canada
but elsewhere in the world can
take advantage of this
new uh vaccination that has been
approved by
health canada
and it can be good for a lot of other
humans living elsewhere on the planet
ryan tumulty postmedia
yeah heather um this question is i guess
probably for doctor new uh i wanted to
ask um since we are you know opening up
to the world a little bit more here
again i wonder if you can talk about
improvements to sort of international
disease surveillance that we might have
made over the last two years
i'm thinking of gfin but you know more
broadly are we better positioned to be
able to see outbreaks happening some
other part of the world
uh thank you very much uh for the
question it's dr new and uh yes i can
say that uh certainly uh uh there's been
a lot of lessons learned over the past
few years and amongst them obviously in
terms of uh continuing continually
improving enhancing our surveillance
systems not just here at home but also
in terms of collaboration with uh with
partners around the world as you can see
where we're continually uh
looking at what the experience has been
in other countries in terms of you know
their epidemic curves or what their
experience has been with various
variants uh how their vaccine rolled out
has progressed and and how that's sort
of affected their epidemic uh situation
uh certainly uh uh that that's something
i think we'll just continue to build on
so i would say that the short answer to
your question say yes i think overall
surveillance systems across the world
but also the interconnectedness of
surveillance systems uh certainly has
improved over the past two years
and then just following up on that um
are you looking to to set up a system
maybe where we would examine specific
countries and might invoke
specific national travel bans in future
if we saw i know there's a couple places
in the world that have seen particularly
high covert rates in the last few weeks
that's a difficult question because uh
certainly as we look at the data that
comes out of the
various countries we recognize that you
know
not all countries may have the capacity
to be uh reporting
as accurately uh compared to other
countries and we certainly don't want to
uh you know penalize a specific
countries for their ability to to be
able to to report more rapidly i think
the recent experience with uh south
africa and i think kudos again to them
for being among the first to detect the
omicron variant i think
uh uh there is a sort of a a sort of a
lesson learned there in terms of how we
could or should be reacting as the world
so i would say that uh i think we're all
in it together i think in terms of a
worldwide surveillance systems and i
think it's not really a sort of aimed at
picking out specific countries but that
that we all need to be working together
to strengthen our be able to detect uh
new variants that that come along and
then be able to as to say in a in a in a
prudent fashion uh react in in the
appropriate fashion across the world and
not as they say focus on specific
countries
my question is ministers
mr de claude i'd like to go back to
kevin galker's question
you said that
the third dose
part of the regular vaccine regime
so i'd like to know
what does it give
to maintain this
vaccination requirement at two doses
when we know that it doesn't provide
adequate
coverages two doses we know it doesn't
do that much thank you elen and i
like to
rectify something two doses it's much
better than zero doses
yes two doses doesn't protect perfectly
against 19.
but there's no vaccine that
protects people against disease 100
so two doses does continue to afford
good protection
it didn't do so well with the omicron
variant but it does provide protection i
think 70 percent
is the protection rate that now
this is the the rate that's used for uh
determining the effect efficacy of
vaccines for other diseases so two doses
does continue according
well depending on the person but it does
continue to provide good protection
it also depends on the
amount of time elapsed between the first
and second dose
but it's not as good as a third dose
and that's why we're encouraging
all those who are listing us to go and
get their booster dose if it's not if it
hasn't already been done but minister do
chloe why maintain this vaccine
obligation
and i'm talking here about travelers
obviously but also federal public
employees who
have had to get a vaccination
i can see that the things
these restrictions are dropping off in
other provinces do you have any
attention to
abandon this vaccine obligation
as i said earlier
all of the measures
are subject to review and we will
continue to review these measures based
on what we learn
[Music]
we see that there's a waning off of
effect efficacy
we don't know how it will present itself
but all the measures will be
reviewed but the message i want to say
the main message i want to convey is two
doses is better than nothing
else
you need to have mandatory
vaccination
at
hi thanks for taking our questions uh a
question for minister jukhloe about the
reporting of covid that you're expecting
to keep in place uh manitoba has said
that it will report covid similar to
influenza which means news uh uh you
know weekly reports on hospitalizations
and severity but not the actual number
of cases unless they end up in hospital
does vac have a plan for what types of
data it will keep requesting from
provinces
and what will ottawa's reporting look
like going forward
thank you uh dylan for
many different and good questions i'll
try to answer them as concisely and as
fairly as possible first on provinces
and territories as we
know i think after two years of japan
they make each province and each
territory makes its own decisions based
on the local context
and the local public health advice
the second you are correct in signaling
the fact that we not only do we know
less about kobe 19 than we would have
say just a few months ago because of the
lower
accessibility availability of pcr
testing
but we also know that this
epidemiological situation will keep
changing with with with new variants and
new waves so
fewer
tools using the traditional pcr
molecular tests but
need a continuing need to keep
monitoring the situation fortunately
p hack has made significant
advances in using the use for instance
of wastewater data i look forward to uh
to be hack in the near future uh more
reporting to you
as journalists and possibly others on
the on the usefulness uh and the key
usefulness of that
additional source of information on the
epidemiology of kobe 19 in canada in
addition to what you have you have would
have noted that
when travelers enter canada there is a
random selection of them a pcr test is
uh is is
the is off is applied to them so they go
through a pcr test randomly and that
gives us information you know
very very very strong and useful
information on the
size of of the population that enters
into canada with different variants
where they come from so it complements
all of the other uh surveillance methods
that doctor and you alluded to uh
earlier so i would say that um different
governments do different things at the
federal level we are
using further tools to keep monitoring
and therefore fighting the virus
thank you and for my follow-up i just
wanted to to ask i i think the medical
officers of health will have to discuss
how they anticipate reporting going
forward but i'm just wondering in terms
of the the types of material that we see
come through the flu watch program you
know we're talking about the
hospitalizations we're talking about how
many severe cases there are
at this point do you have any sort of an
indication of of what we might actually
want to expect you know as these
restrictions ease in terms of what type
of surveillance of the virus will
continue over the coming months
well for that uh great question maybe we
should turn to dr new uh dr new would
you like to explain
how p hack is working in this uh new
environment connecting different types
of data and to support the monitoring
made and by provinces and territories
yes uh thank you very much for the
question dylan it's a doctor you're here
and you're right uh
we continue at the federal level uh the
public health agency of canada working
closely with our counterparts in the
provinces and territories and what we're
looking towards is is as you say uh
having more of a quote an integrated
surveillance system so it's a number of
different initiatives as a minister
duklow mentioned uh uh certainly a very
new and innovative tool is the
wastewater surveillance which can
sometimes give us an early signal in
terms of what a community might expect
in terms of maybe a subsequent increase
in actual uh number of cases of
infection among among
its citizens and then obviously as
control measures are put in place the
wastewater surveillance is also a a tool
to be able to monitor the effect of
effectiveness of those control measures
as hopefully you know the uh the sort of
indications or indicator uh indicators
of wastewater surveillance hopefully go
down so that that's one initial uh new
tool that we're also uh expanding right
now i think it's about 60 coverage
across sort of municipalities and so on
canada we're hopefully trying to
increase that to 80 and even more in the
future so that's one tool uh for respect
uh with respect to the severity
indicators uh certainly we're we're
expecting to continue receiving uh
on a regular basis from the province and
territories hospitalization data and
other uh severity indicators including
deaths that to show us uh uh what might
be happening with respect to uh uh you
know uh only let's say uh covert 19
general but obviously maybe the impact
of of a specific variance and of course
besides the severity indicators our
ongoing monitoring in terms of uh actual
infections continues uh with the
provinces and territories for example as
you pointed out it may not necessarily
be a case of having to detect every
single case but maybe more towards what
we're doing for our flu surveillance as
you pointed out having sentinel sites uh
like like flu watchers looking at other
indicators like maybe absenteeism rates
you know in schools and workplaces and
then of course it's important to uh
continuously on a regular basis sample
and actually do the genetic sequencing
of uh individual cases to be able to
monitor uh what what might be happening
with a shifting a sort of mixture of uh
variants in the country and as the
minister pointed out on top of that
we'll have our border surveillance to be
able to detect
potentially the emergence of new
variants around the world with respect
to travelers coming into the to the
country so uh it is all-encompassing and
uh there's lots of lots of work underway
as they say behind the scenes uh another
thing i might mention is that we're also
leveraging our existing uh sentinel
sites uh for example in hospitals we
have a a sentinel system with some key
hospitals we're also able to give us
some key uh data that we might need
moving forward so i think i'll leave it
at that and certainly uh happy to uh
maybe get into more detail maybe hit a a
future pressure that dr tim and i will
be giving
chelsea
my question is
do not have to have these requirements
anymore okay
thank you very much for your question
on
and for
the entire population
you want to look at the number of
vaccinations well that gets interesting
because
we talk about being up to date with the
vaccinations
rather than looking at the
number of doses of vaccination for
instance
we know that it's not
just the number of vaccine doses that's
important
the interval between the doses because
we know
that in some countries
people may have received two three or
even four doses but if the doses uh uh
given at an interval like the one we
have here in canada perhaps the humanity
is not as robust as it may be here in
canada because here
we in the valley have an intervention
now we're talking about getting a
booster six months later here in canada
what's happening at the borders
a transition is occurring there are a
lot of travelers arriving here in canada
you know from other countries
that are not as lucky as canada
uh kapab that they accepted the voice
epithet
that's something
we'll continue to look at what's
happening in other countries we'll look
at the data and we will adjust our
policy
uh accordingly
we okay thank you
i heard what you had to say but have you
recommended the current uh two-dose
formula or will you be calculating uh
another type of formula
we know that
the number of vaccinations recommended
in canada
we know that
that in order to have a stronger
protection
immunity
from
talking about the need for booster doses
for eligible people here in canada
more than six months ago but for
travelers there are other considerations
that we have to take into account to
date we accept two doses but obviously
we're going to look at the data
and we will take all of this data into
account and provide our recommendations
to the minister here
in canada but for the time being
this is
this is
what the case is
so 10 minutes remaining quite a few uh
reporters that have questions so just if
we can keep our answers short it would
be great uh all of yesterfanovich scbc
thank you good morning
you're making this announcement at a
time when the who is warning about the
spread of coba 19 particularly the ba2
variant worldwide so i'm wondering is
this really the right time to be making
these changes and how prepared are you
to rule these changes back if there is a
spike in cases across the country
well thank you olivia for that great
question well as you will have heard
they we we have and we will have seen
over the last months we keep
following the situation and change and
adjust the rules as required taking into
account both the domestic and the
international situation over the last
few weeks
just to give you uh perhaps some some
some
numbers the last few weeks we've seen a
significant decrease in the rates of
positivity of travelers entering into
canada that rate was approx almost 10
percent in in january that which means
that
one out of 10 travelers in january
entering into canada was positive with
corvid that
was
significantly larger obviously than what
we had seen in december in december and
prior to that that rate has fallen to
about one percent now so no there are
there is a there is obviously
alignment between that rate and what we
see internally in canada and outside of
canada
that's this being said you are entirely
correct in the world according to the
who there is an increase in
the overall global
number of cases uh most like most
importantly in some regions of asia and
some parts of europe so
we are going to keep monitoring the
situation as dr new mentioned earlier we
are going to use
mrt mandatory random testing to do that
on a
region country specific basis and if we
see that we need to adjust measures we
will obviously do that because as randy
and
omar also mentioned we are mindful of
the importance of focusing on the health
and safety of everyone
how much longer do you expect travelers
to be required to wear masks on planes
and trains
maybe i should turn to minister agabra
for that question
uh
thank you janie
so look the
um
we'll continue to rely on the advice
that we receive from our public health
and we will adjust our measures
as as the situation evolves but
we're also just like we will
ease our measures if things
uh appear to be um
evolving in a negative direction we will
also have to adjust our measures
accordingly so we just need to be nimble
maintaining uh that we're protecting the
public health and safety of canadians
and and and i agree obviously and and
and
minister again
i should have pointed to dr new uh as
well because you know wearing a mask is
is something that uh
comes with uh obviously some
inconvenience no individually we'd all
prefer not to wear a mask
uh for all sorts of obvious reasons but
you know the health benefits of wearing
a mask in particular in crowded areas
like a plane
or train that are also well known so
i'm going to turn back to you again
because i know time is too short
yeah
this is dr neuer i just couldn't mention
that just from a public health
perspective certainly uh the use of face
masks is a a personal protective measure
it's another layer of protection that we
certainly would recommend and certainly
in the context of uh being as as
minister to khloe and mr algabra said if
you're an enclosed space like say an
airplane you know for an extended period
of time i think it just makes sense that
we've always talked about uh avoiding
the three c's or at least being being
careful what you do in the three seas
you know having crowded close uh spaces
with close contact so i think at a
personal level i would certainly think
you know it doesn't matter if there's a
mandate or not i think it's just a good
practice to keep wearing a face mask in
certain contexts thank you
[Music]
russian or russian planes across
canadian skies could you provide some
clarification
what is the process
and is it the department of transport
that manages the situation
or is it now in the hands of the
minister of defense
thank you for the question um look from
the beginning we've been
outlining comprehensive measures
to respond to the unprovoked attack by
russia on ukraine
when we've expressed our solidarity with
ukraine and the ukrainian people in this
moment of of need
part of our measures have uh been back
to ban russian flights from canadian
airspace and russian boats from canadian
air uh canadian uh waters
and we've now
accelerated or expanded these measures
to include uh belarusian uh uh planes
uh so these the this uh no tam it's done
under a no tam notice to airmen uh
mechanism where we issue
uh uh a an advice or a warning to to
uh
air operators
that if they uh
if they feel if they are part of the uh
of those measures they need to they must
avoid canadian airspace and nav canada
the air traffic control body is uh
responsible for enforcing that so
they're
uh
so operators and pilots are notified
before getting close to uh
to canadian airspace that if uh if there
are a russian owned or charted plane or
if there are belarus in owned or
chartered plane they are not allowed to
enter canadian airspace
we talked about what it means to be
adequately vaccinated foreigners
who are not vaccinated with
canadian approved vaccinations are not
considered as being
fully vaccinated is that something that
you are going to change eventually
and do we know
how many people cannot uh
enter canada because of that reason
thank you mr pippo
there are a few exceptions
not going to enumerate because i'm sure
to miss a few
but
there are
exemptions for
foreign temporary workers a small
percentage of them are not vaccinated
but they can enter
canada providing the quarantine for 14
days but generally speaking you're quite
right
you have to be vaccinated to come into
canada as a general rule a lot of
countries uh well
a lot of people who want to visit us
and they have high vaccination rates
sometimes even
they come from countries with a higher
vaccinate rate
so
very few people are excluded
we have time for one final question
since we have a few people still with
the uh with our hands up uh maybe you
guys can share a uh a a question and a
follow-up so we would go to valeri
gamash and then maybe global news
[Music]
can you hear me
you can hear me yes i can hear you
i'd like to
what impact will this have on kovacs
and what impact will it have with
respect to w.h.o
first of all
perhaps i didn't say it clearly enough
but the decision
made by who has not been taken yet and
we want to ensure with medicaid that the
information
is shared
between the two organizations
what i did say and i'm happy to repeat
this medical is good for canada and
canadians but it's also good for
for
other countries because this is the
unique type of technology
and it will strengthen
the range of
technologies used to produce
vaccinations throughout the world it's a
really good piece of news that this is a
canadian company
it will really do a lot for our
pharmaceutical sector and it's very good
for the future and vaccinating people
against covid
i do understand but who has clear rules
it's
it says that cigarettes are the biggest
[Music]
are you trying to get around the rules
so
what's the story there
we are ensuring
that who has all the information that
medical has
a very solid reputation so if health
canada
approves a vaccination that will really
help
the vaccination get approved elsewhere
so
health canada's approval is sending a
very clear signal and so who will have
to look at this information and all
other available information in order to
make a decision apparently this is all
the time that we have
um i'm sorry that for the reporters that
are still
on the line thank you ministers merci
beaucoup turmoil